I'm Justin I'm a scientist at the Allen
Institute and I'm going to be talking to
you today a little bit about a little
bit about what the Ellen Institute does
some of the some of the things that
we're building and how how Python is a
is a key aspect of our of our software
architecture hang on
so the Elenin suit for brain science
we've been around for a few years we the
the larger organization I've not been
here for for its entirety and the
altitudes kind of interesting and unique
in it in terms of research institutes so
we have a have a very strong commitment
to open data and we take a big science
team science approach to what we what we
produce and over the years we have
released multiple very large data sets
that are of general value to the
neuroscience community and our most
recent data set is the Allen Brain
Observatory which was released last May
and we've had two subsequent releases of
it as well and that's what I'm going to
be talking a little bit about today we
have a and what is the point of that of
the Allen Brain Observatory so within
the visual system we have a sense of
different brain regions which do
different things so the retina seems to
maintain I have the retina seems to
maintain visual information a very
vertical represent a a somewhat vertical
representation of the world and as the
as the the neurons project up through
the through the visual system as we go
to to increasingly deep layers of the
brain the representations get more and
more complex and this this architecture
has has inspired you know many neural
network architectures that you guys
might be familiar with where you know an
image of a cat you know eventually gets
becomes represented as as the the
concept of a cat and a lot of this work
has been done in in primate models but
this model this you know this data this
are
texture is insufficient to explain a lot
of what we know about how the brain
works and there's kind of two key things
that I want to highlight that this this
model is insufficient to characterize
one is that within each of these
different colored layers there's
actually multiple different types of
cells and there's characteristic ways
that those cells are connected to each
other in order to form kind of local
computational circuits that isn't is it
really captured in these in these simple
models and secondarily there's also a
lot more of the brain here and the way
that these representations in the way
that these different parts of the brain
work may change based on the demands on
an animal so if an animal if you are or
a person so if you are looking for a cat
or trying to attend to a certain region
looking for a cat in a certain area you
might you might miss the cat that is the
somewhere else in your visual scene if
you are so depending on your motivation
depending on what on what you're trying
to do the way that the that these
different different layers might might
might work can change so the brain
Observatory is is the Allen Institute
attempt to basically survey the the
visual system and particularly in the
mouse visual cortex and one of the
reasons that we are looking in the mouth
visual cortex is that we can identify
and we can create transgenic animals who
have cells in their brain that glow
under that glow when they are active and
we can specify certain certain cells to
fluoresce when they are active we can
then record from multiple different
visual areas so this is a image of the
of the surface of the mouse brain with
different visual areas highlighted and
we can zoom in on using a microscope
zoom in on the particular field of view
a particular region and record these
cells actually firing and actually
active while we're presenting a bunch of
images on the screen and so based on all
of these images we can then
look at characteristic ways that these
cells respond and and this gives us
information about how the visual system
is working and ultimately all of this
data is released online free for you to
use so if you go to brain Observatory
brain map org you can doubt you can you
know browse this data yourself right now
if you do pip install Allen SDK then you
have our entire data set of 40,000
neurons at your fingertips I'm not going
to be talking to you about all of the
all the the kind of ETL the the data
pipeline that we have for this entire
data set but instead I'm going to talk
to you a little bit more about how we
get there so we have a in order to
generate these data sets we have a
number of teams that whose activities
are coordinated who have different roles
in producing these data so we have
surgery teams who do the surgeries we
have our behavior team that that helps
train mice we have our physiology team
that does actual recordings and um at
the end of the day one of the one of our
goals is to really understand this full
cycle of of of how the brain works in
the entire system that the brain works
in so what I describe to you so far mice
were simply sitting in front of a screen
with images being presented to them and
that captures kind of this this
environment perception corner of this
loop but ultimately when we're really
talking about what the brain does in the
world the brain you know our brains we
use that information to make decisions
we use that information to make
decisions that we can then act on those
decisions when we act on those decisions
that changes the world around us
and so there's a full cycle that we'd
like to capture and so in order to do
that we actually need to train my studio
we are while we are recording and so we
are building out a visual behavior brain
observatory in which will expand out a
very key piece of this of this data
production pipeline in to be able to
train mice in a couple of weeks to be
able to make decisions about things they
see
so that when we go to record from them
they're also making decisions about what
they see and we can capture that full
that full cycle so in order to do this
though we need to train mice at scale so
how do we how do we train mice at scale
well the key key pieces is that we need
to automate whatever we can
whatever we can't automate we need to be
able to support our trainers and beyond
that we just need to be able to iterate
and and improve our ability to Train
animals so the first piece of this so
the the basic tasks that we're going to
be presenting to animals and challenging
them to do is to lick a water spout when
they see an image change so we're going
to have multiple images that are
presented on the screen and when the
image changes they need to look at water
spout and in order to Train animals do
this there's a very basic algorithm
that's been been formalized for many
years and used for many years beyond
that to reinforce their their behavior
and basically we follow this little this
little graph so did the image change if
the image changed then we asked the
mouse respond if the mouse did respond
then they get a reward Mouse did not
respond then maybe it'll get a reward
next time on the other hand if the image
did not change and the mouse responds
then they need to be be present to the
trial again and if they did not respond
correctly then they'll get another
chance soon now this this basic logic
has been has been used for many many
years so here's a here's some some cats
that have learned a similar task they've
learned that when they ring the bell
then they their owner gives them a
little bit of food and you know this
owner has basically scaled this up
effectively to two animals but it's much
harder to scale this strategy up to
dozens of animals simultaneously which
is what we need to be able to do luckily
it's pretty easy to get to get computers
to do some of this for us so our key
challenges that we face in scaling
behavior
is first we need to be able to minimize
the the intervention of actual of our
trainers during training we need to be
able to let our trainers monitor some
perform the animals performance during
training our scientists need to be able
to analyze the behavior both for its
scientific value but also to be able to
iterate and improve our training because
ultimately we want to be able to
minimize the training time so that we
can fit this into into this whole
production workflow so I'm going to be
walking through each of these and
talking about how you know kind of the
tools that we've built out into our
software architecture to solve these
challenges so here's our my overview
slide and I'm going to drill into these
shortly of our software architecture so
effectively down here at the at the
bottom we have kind of our file storage
files and databases we have a service
layer that helps to help to mediate our
interactions with these the big blue box
up on the left there is our behavior
control workstation which is where the
primary point of interaction with
trainers and then the other blue boxes
or other containers and I'm going to go
through and talk about what all these
are
so first the core of for the oh yeah
for my our first challenge is to
minimize trainer intervention and so our
basic solution here is to automate our
training algorithm and to be able to
support efficient trainer workflows so
this all first and foremost gets drilled
down into this one yellow box which is
our actual task our task is just a
Python script that runs on the on the on
a computer this basically implements
this logic that I talked to you about
before in a in a task flow so there are
different windows that when you know we
we say okay we're going to wait until it
until a change might happen we have some
window in which a change might occur a
change if a change occurs and we're
going to have a window in which we
listen for responses so this all was has
been implemented in software largely
used
being cutie pie cutie to handle cutie
events so that this can be all be
asynchronous and we can just trigger
these these windows off of each other
all of our hardware interactions so
actually monitoring the mouse the
mouse's behavior and controlling the
solenoid to present water is using PI
dak MX which controls National
Instruments cards all the images that
are being presented on the screen is
using the psycho PI toolbox and then and
then we this also uses some 0 mq to in
order to publish events and live which
I'll be talking about shortly we need to
be able to scale this up though and
here's one of our here's one of our
behavior training rooms so each of these
boxes the is a training box
those little syringes or where the water
comes from that's the the reward for the
animal off to the left and right are two
of our control workstations that our
trainers use to actually interact with
it to interact with the mice so in order
to scale this up though and down there
along the very bottom are the actual
computers that are running the software
for them so we need to be able to take
our tasks and we need to be able to
deploy it because this is being running
on multiple different different
computers so we basically have a task
deployment GUI that the trainers can use
to load up the the tasks for an animal
this can actually read directly from our
service layer to identify the proper the
proper task to give to the animal this
uses 0 mq to send to send that script
and its associated parameters to it the
agent that's running on the on the
computer that the mouse's computer the
agent then deploys the task which runs
and then when the task is done
it saves itself to dock onto onto disk
so that we can look at the data later
nicely though because we have to every
single every single control computer
control six individual computers and so
this gets deployed in parallel we've got
a nice little GUI that was all written
in QT in order to in order to load this
stuff up and then to use a zero I'm cute
to send things along to deploy the
actual tasks we want to be able to make
this even easier for our trainers though
so this interface where as we can sit
here and type things in if we want to
minimize the errors for our trainers
we've actually made it even easier such
that the the trainers only have to scan
a barcode on the mouse's on the mouse's
cage they scan a barcode on the training
chamber and then they just have to click
run in script GUI which is the name of
our of our of our little task deployer
and it runs so our next challenge is to
be able to let our trainers monitor
performance of the animals during
training so our solution to this is to
stream our training data and to present
our visualizations on a central
dashboard so here's the our our
dashboard so these are just a web it was
just web interfaces that that present
the an overview for each trainer they've
got a tab they can click on they get
their overview of the the data as the
mouse is running and this gets
constantly regularly updated with with
with the most recent data from a given
Mouse and then we can drill in down to
get more specific plots from from
individual mice as they're running as
well and so this is all basically built
on top of tornado presenting the web web
service again using PI's iam dmq to
handle 0 mq messaging and then using
Vega to define our plots and so each of
our each of our computers that the tasks
are each actually running on are then
publishing regularly which goes off to
an accumulator that pools all the data
together
then bounces it back up back off to our
monitoring dashboard which presents the
web interface that our trainers can then
use so our other challenges that our
scientists need to actually be able to
analyze this behavior as well and the
analyzed animals behavior so
unsurprisingly
perhaps we have a built in we built out
a you know shared analysis and
visualization package that we use
internally in order to load up this data
and analyze it so these this package
basically we have a bunch of standard
plots that we use that that we can
analyze after every single behavioral
session we can analyze that animal data
get some summary information on the left
here is a is one of our plots for a
single session that our scientists use
in order to analyze animal's behavior on
our right is a summary of that animal
over multiple days and so we can
generate these plots every night so that
our scientists can can get a feel for
how a given animal is doing and how its
progressing through its training and
this is all built on top of numpy scipy
matplotlib panda Seabourn kind of a
standard scientific analysis stack this
also you know once we since we've built
this all kind of on top of pandas in
addition to doing kind of these standard
reports that we that we push out we can
also drill down into more in-depth
analysis you know so we've got jupiter
notebooks and we can drill down into
more specific analyses so here's some
analysis that I did a couple months ago
looking at the census sensitivity to a
bunch of different mice along the x-axis
there to the timing of of when the
changes occurred so this was just to see
whether or not animals could we're
sensitive to when these changes were
happening and whether they that was
affecting their their behavior and
indeed it seems to for most animals
we're able to do a lot of fun things
with this so this is one of our we've
got some we've been exploring training
animals to discriminate between digits
in the MA
data set so we can flash multiple zeroes
within the Emnes data set and then at
some point it changes to a one and the
animal needs to lick if the category
changed but not if the individual and
this exemplar changed and so indeed and
so what this is plotting is the the
likelihood of an animal licking for any
given combination and any given
transition between between the digits so
the dark purple boxes indicates that the
animals are less likely to lick within
the categories changes but more likely
to lick when the categories do change so
effectively our behavior analysis
package kind of sits over here that it's
largely kind of reading out from this
from our data stores in order to in
order to analyze our data so one of our
final challenges is that we need to be
able to automatically progress mice
through these training stages so we have
a lot of mice going simultaneously we
can get a in order to train these mice
to to do something like the EM this data
set we can't start them on something
fairly complex on day one instead we
need to start them on a much easier
version of the task and then and then
move them on to harder versions of it of
a task so what we've done is we've
automated our analysis of past behavior
in order to determine future training
parameters and so effectively what we
what we can define is we can define a
graph we can define a graph of stages of
training that in in the simplest version
goes is linear and goes from easy to
hard so every node in this graph is a
training stage with a set of parameters
that are associated with it and then
each transition can occur that animal
can advance the next training stage if
some performance criteria is met so
every day we analyze the we need to
analyze their their behavior if they're
doing well enough on the task then then
they can get get tripped on and go to
the next stage in the task
this is all built using a combination of
0 mq in order to monitor when animals
are done with the with the task but all
of the the state machine logic is is
done using Python package called
transitions which is fantastic for for
defining these kinds of state machines
and so this automatic training algorithm
basically sits here and monitors the
accumulator in order to get updates for
wind for when the animals done with a
with a training session when the animals
done with the training session that
triggers an analysis from our automatic
training algorithm that uses the
packages you know our analysis packages
that we've developed to analyze their
behavior and then makes a decision on on
whether the parameters need to change or
not if the parameters do need to change
then that gets saved back down into the
into our data store which then on the
next day can get loaded back up
automatically by our by our trainers
when they scan the barcode so kind of is
an overview for some of the you know I
think one of the things that's that's
remarkable about this is that that you
know this isn't just you know one little
corner of analysis that's using Python
that are our entire architecture is
built using Python at every level you
know everything from from dealing with
distributed messaging down to hardware
control all the way up to you know
building out our web visualizations and
building out our scientific analysis and
so this is all you know that this just
kind of I think highlights a lot of the
points that the Jake was making earlier
about the power of Python in the data
science sphere as being not just about
data science but about this single tool
that can that has so many other
components to it that they can all work
together
so using this basically over the past
few months we've been we've been trying
to iterate and improve our training in
order to get the our animals into
trained up fast enough to be able to
work within our pipeline so here's a
summary plot that I put together so
here's the number of training days each
color here is a different cohort of
animals that all had similar training
parameters going from the darkest being
our oldest cohort to the lightest being
our most recent cohorts and so over this
time we basically been able to increase
our throughput and decrease our training
time which ultimately will get us ready
to be able to deploy this into our our
full data generation pipeline and
hopefully around well I'm not going to
make any promises on time but at some
point in the not-too-distant future I
hope we'll be able to deploy all this
data will get deployed to along with all
the Allen Institute other data products
to Observatory brain maps org and you'll
be able to download all of it with a
simple type install so I'd like to think
especially all the people who work on
the different components of this so the
neural coding group are manufacturing a
process engineering group our modeling
analysis and theory group as well as our
neural surgery and behavior group who
trained up all the mice we have I know
that we've got jobs open for software
engineers and for scientists so if
you're interested in kind of things we
do you should check out the website and
more than anything you know like to
thank Paul Allen and and Jody Allen for
their for their immense and continued
support thank you very much
[Applause]
Thanks before I go to questions there's
a quick announcement I have to make so
if you're in this room you're in the
correct room for the pop quiz so the pub
quiz that's coming up after the talk is
going to be held here however you can
have the pop quiz if you don't have if
you're in the pipe you have to drink
something so there's going to be drinks
outside and so I don't know how long the
questions are going to take we do have
about 20 minutes there probably there'll
be time but if not just so you know if
you want to have a drink at the quiz you
should step out at some point during the
questions to get a drink and come back
so that we can start on time okay so
okay let's open up the floor for
questions
what are the range of things that the
that's a good question
let's see what's the Alan SDK what do we
have in there I've had some colleagues
out there who can help me answer these
questions too I think Nick might be that
are better able to so the Alan SDK has
access to three major data resources the
cell types database or the occult the ID
FCC the in vitro single-cell
characterization pipeline which is a
comprehensive study of the intracellular
voltage of I think I don't know how many
thousands of cells but thousands of
cells there's the brain Observatory
which is a two-photon imaging so looking
at the cortical responses of populations
of neurons to passive viewing a visual
stimuli and then what's currently pulled
up on my laptop that I was just browsing
through it's the mouse connectivity
Atlas which is a comprehensive track
tracing in three dimensions of the
axonal projections through of different
cell types throughout the mouse brain so
accessing the raw data pre-processed
preliminary results and out and also
algorithms that were used in the
processing pipeline those are the things
anyone else actually I have a question
the slide that you showed at the very
end with the progress in training time
yeah it's a kind of double question what
were some of the things that you changed
to improve that training time and
secondly was it just trial and error or
do you have some more sophisticated ways
of figuring out the kind of features
that improve training time yeah I mean
it's one of these things that I'm going
to t we have I mean there's a long
history of some of this behavioral
psychology work and so I mean ultimately
we're talking to behavioral psychology
when we talk about training the animals
and so part of it is that we have that
there are kind of known tricks that it's
kind of wondering whether we need to
pull these things together into a grab
bag so a little bit of it is trial and
error so for example we there are
there's questions about the timing of
the distributions or or whether or not
you know if the animal is in a timeout
period whether you give them feedback on
that
so for some of those those questions we
basically if we had a candidate
intervention we did some within cohort
splits so sort of like an a/b test to be
able to do explicit comparisons
ultimately some of the I mean some of
the key the key pieces that that
facilitated the the timing speed was or
the this training speed one of the
basically had to do with the timing of
the distribution so when was were these
changes likely to occur and to prevent
the animals from guessing that too much
so forcing basically an exponential
distribution sampling from an
exponential distribution instead of a
uniform distribution and then the other
one is basically making the early
stimuli as easy as possible so that
training time that I plotted there it's
a little bit so that was was that
basically they're the amount of time to
get out of stage one so that was the you
know the first day that we knew that
that the animals were actually paying
attention to the screen that they were
doing something where they were looking
at what they were making decisions based
on what they saw on the screen so
basically by changing from a kind of
hard to see stimulus to a very salient
you know big white and black lines on
the screen was was one of the major
changes that that helped help support
training times and then pairing that
with automated training algorithms and
implementing the automated training
algorithms that as soon as we get get a
sense of an animal you know that that's
performing well then the training
algorithm can kick them on to the next
stage instead of a scientist getting
distracted going off to a conference for
three days and you know forgetting to
check whether or not they should advance
him along yes generations of mice
trained their offspring they've never
seen like this
yeah that's a good question I I don't
know specifically so so these mice so
these mites have been have been bred
particularly for these transgenic
indicators so they are you know so
they're they're bred so they have this
this this protein that flores's in very
specific cells so all of our breeding
strategies are centered around around
those issues I think it's a it's a
probably amazing I think it's a
fascinating question and it gets to a it
gets to it gets into very complicated
questions I think in the field of
neuroscience in general about some of
these like nature versus nurture
questions and what what is you know what
aspects of behavior are endogenous what
what you know whether you come along
with when you're born what do you what
you can you learn along the way yeah but
I I'm not I don't know off the top my
head of anything that has really looked
at that explicitly in this context so
yes
Oh
yes yes
so the yeah you mean you mean in the
context of the training itself or
totally absolutely yeah yes so basically
that's one of the key questions that
that we need to like ask and validate
within a data set so for example how do
I go back here so the sorry
there we go okay so like for this I
think this M this data is a good example
so to what extent is this Mouse so this
mouse is able to you know for the most
part responds doesn't respond when zeros
go to zeros but does respond zeros go to
other digits is that because they have
extracted the higher-level features of
these images so that they have a sense
of their own Asst and oneness or is it
or the that you know basically there's
light in the center of the screen or not
and that's me that's a basically an
active area of inquiry so in order for
me to make a strong claim here that this
mouse is doing some categorical
discrimination or has some categorical
perception I'm not willing to make that
claim right now but I think that it's
it's it's very interesting though to be
able to pair that with the types of
neural data that we can get because what
you might expect is that that basically
we have a sense of different parts of
the brain you know being being involved
in these different types of decisions in
different ways and so ultimately
whatever we train animals up on and
deploy to be able to download like you
know you yourself would be able to go
and download that data and say okay like
is this area you know responding to
these images at categories or is it
responding to these images as you know
some low-level feature that that can
they can better explain what this cell
is doing so
okay anyone else okay
let's thank the speaker one more time
thank you
[Applause]